[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois macha méril les
présidentes d'honneur du 6e festival du
cinéma russe qui dure à paris jusqu'au 9
mars et elle publie un roman vania
vassia et la fille de bastia sur les
cosaques émigré en france après la
révolution bolchévique yves michaud pour
son livre ceci n'est pas une tulipe sur
l'enlaidissement des villes par
l'encombrement des oeuvres d'art alexis
sachka pour son nouvel album comme un
ours il sera le lympia le 18 avril et
florence dupré la tour pour un nouveau
volet de son autobiographie en bande
destinée puceul mais commençons d'être
comme d'habitude par notre époque qu'est
ce qui la caractérise voici votre
réponse florence dupré la tour en images
alors de quoi s'agit-il alors je crois
que tout le monde connaît cette image
qui est issue la culture populaire c'est
un oeil de sauront attirer du seigneur
des anneaux
alors moi je viens d'une culture
chrétienne pendant pendant très
longtemps très petit j'ai été soumise à
l'oeil de dieu et avoir tout à l'heure
voilà on va le voir tout à l'heure et je
suis devenu athée et c'est quelque chose
qui me faisait très peur le regard de
dieu sur moi qui me qui me servait tout
le temps et petit à petit avec l'arrivée
de la surveillance généralisée des êtres
humains je me retrouve dans la même
situation et ça m'angoisse énorme et
mérite donc toujours surveillés mais
plus par dieu voilà mais toujours
surveillés alexis hk votre image c'est
celle ci alors elle et elle est vrai de
vrai oui non c'est pas une photo de
famille c'est une image assez connue qui
a beaucoup circulé quand elle est sortie
et c'est une image qui me trouble
beaucoup parce que au premier regard on
a envie de juger ces vacanciers donc au
premier plan sont des vacanciers au
second plan c'est un
voilà nous perçoit y échouer à noyers et
c'est vraiment une photo qui pose la
question des photos justement et de ce
qu'on peut ressentir devant une photo on
aurait envie de juger ces deux touristes
qui l'a qui regarde cette personne et en
même temps on sait pas ce qu'ils ont
fait juste après si ça se trouve ils
sont précipités pour venir en aide à
ceux à cette personne échoué ou pas et
elle me trouve le beaucoup parce que
c'est une photo nh à regard à plusieurs
temps où il faut à mon avis éviter de
juger ces deux touristes qui eux ont
tout ils ont la glacière le coca ils
seront le parasol et puis on a sept
personnes qui naquit la rien et c'est
deux mondes qui se confrontent comme ça
c'est l'addition jugent ces deux
touristes on est obligé de se juger tous
puisque les actes eux mans on se demande
on se demande l'instant d'après ce qu'on
nous demande aurait pour ce qu'on aurait
ressemblé ça fait partie des photos
chocs qui ont circulé qui ont circulé
mais la question c'est même pas attendre
que ce soit un montage ce qu'elle
raconte quelque chose d'elle même et on
saura jamais si c'est un montage ou pas
mais en tout cas laissé un regard en
plusieurs temps que je trouve que je
trouve intéressant et troublant et qui
représentent notre époque parce que
voilà notre époque est vraiment divisée
entre les privilégiés puis ceux qui
essayent d'avoir d'attendre des
privilèges et qui tout au moins une vie
décente et qu'ils n'y arrivent pas
forcément et qui peuvent finale comme ça
et lexie eux n'ont suffi yves michaud
alors on voit derrière le bouquet de
tulipes offert par jeff koons sonné à la
ville de paris on y reviendra bien et le
point de départ de votre livre mais au
premier abord ça doit être la fashion
week
alors c'est la fashion week s'est étiré
du hem le magazine le supplément du
monde là
de samedi dernier c'est une photo des
photos du regretté leur qui est allé
faire poser les modèles de la fashion
week dans cet endroit qui est en travaux
ce qui m'a intéressé si vous voulez
c'est que je crois que disait symbolique
de l'époque bond à des îlots de luxe au
milieu d'un pandémonium d'objets de
voitures de l'acd scooter et derrière il
doit y avoir un ennemi coup quelque
chose comme ça non serait plutôt une
sorte de fenwick
l'arbre est protégé bien sûr puisqu'il
faut jamais toucher à la nature il faut
absolument la protéger bizarrement
protéger d'ailleurs par les milieux
urbains pas d'argent
un mobilier urbain affreux c'est pas
pour parler du sujet de mon livre mais
ce qu'on sait c'est très parlant sur la
ville actuelle fille dans la ville
actuelle où il ya plus d'urbanisme où
tout part dans tous les sens où c'est un
dépotoir d'objets d'objets d'utilité
parce que les scooters ça sert à quelque
chose
les sculptures c'est avec la question et
lampadaires un dépotoir d'objets et puis
au milieu et bien d'une luxe du rêve de
la beauté il ya une deuxième photo voilà
et j'ai mis une deuxième photo c'est le
même reportage à toute la série comme ça
alors là c'est encore mieux il ya un
skate board et à la voiture il ya le
modèle il ya toujours ce pauvre arbres
qui étaient protégés
et puis à l'ailé cully place que
j'appelle les culs libre de course
puisque tous ses plus des trous du cul
que dès que des tulipes cdc et des
masturbateur pour sex shops et c'est
très typique de la de la ville actuelle
de beaucoup de villes je dirais pas
seulement de paris mais paris
spécialement en ce moment mais vire
c'est très typique est pas alors à tout
et on est en train de remettre le
monument au milieu de la pelouse qu'on a
dévasté pour le m je pense qu'on mettra
peut-être du barbelé auto pour que les
gens aillent pas le tag et écoutez moi
c'est une photo atroce mais qui est
complètement bidon parce que si c'était
vraiment trop plat blocks et piotr pas
bien ce qui je préférerais ne pas
d'avoir montré longuement mais hélas
c'est une nuage très forte qu'on l'a
reçu parce que s'il était vraiment sa
bouche cousue il aurait les cicatrices
qu'il n'a plus donc à mon avis c'est du
cinéma
c'est à dire vous savez
ça au cinéma on peut faire des fausses
couture et des fausses du post cette
phrase cette photo a été causé comme
l'une des 100 photos du siècle je crois
par people magazine m haies alors
c'était cousu la bouche pour protester
contre le régime répressif au pouvoir en
russie
celui de vladimir poutine oui c'est ce
qu'il dit mais c'est complètement faux
parce qu'il n'aurait pas ce sourire la
bouche cousue elle serait tordu et en
plus de ça c'est une belle image n'est
ce pas très flatteuse pour lui pour son
je pense que c'est une des plus
imposants table fait qu news qu'on est
publié et en plus de ça un artiste qui
se mutile ça existe déjà on a orlan
celle née ici voilà oui elle se fabrique
des choses avec son corps donc le beau
dia comme on dit mais ça peut être très
très touchant ça c'est seulement
détestable et quand il sait cloud et les
testicules sur la place rouge vous
ouvrez quand vous imaginez qu'ils aient
cloud et coop ce soit parce que sinon il
n'aurait pas continué à séduire de
jolies femmes
un bon moyen puis si les vigiles quand
même de ce clou et dans le bitume ouais
bravo
alors entre les pavés alors entre les
pavés c'est drôle comme ce gars autour
du temps où ils s'opposaient avait
d'ailleurs poutine était un héros et
maintenant qu'il a moi je le prends pas
aussi la cause et la jument la
différence de le benjamin griveaux
maintenant je prends très au sérieux je
pense que c'est une lignée d'artistes
provocateur qu'on y en a continuellement
eu il ya pire un même censuré des choses
qu'on peut pas voir parce qu'il ya des
provocations nous avons chez les
artistes chinois qui sont bien pires
mais vient on sait jamais tant que la
postérité n'est pas passé on sait jamais
si ce sont des escrocs des héros qui
gagne dans 40 ans si ça se trouve ça
sera une sorte de duchamp ou sinon ça
sera un escroc tout ce qu'ils auront
leur à oublier pour le voilà bien
commençons
[Musique]
macha méril comédienne romancière
princesse également vous venez de
publier vania vassia et la fille de
vassia chez liana levi c'est un roman
sur les russes blancs en france et plus
particulièrement les cosaques alors les
cosaques
s'agit-il d'un peu plus d'un régiment
alors à l'intérieur de l'émigration
russe donc dont je fais partie les
aristocrates des intellectuels il y
avait un groupe qui étaient les cosaques
les cosaques c'est un ordre militaire
ils viennent de partout en russie
c'est pas du tout géographique c'est pas
une ethnie il y en avait les cosaques du
don les cosaques de kuvan les collègues
de terek ils avaient en commun une école
une école extrêmement strictes qui
s'appelait à novotcherkassk
et donc napoléon avait dit donnez moi un
régiment de cosaques jeu pourrait
conquérir l'europe et même le monde
parce que c'était une école tellement
extraordinaire à cheval presque toujours
les photos qu'on voit c'est avant la
guerre de 14 ans assure qu'avant la
révolution alors ils avaient en commun
le tsarisme il était dans la garde
impériale l'orthodoxie
donc ils ont été les premiers ennemis
des bolcheviks ils ont été quelques-uns
ont voulu entrer dans l'armée rouge par
patriotisme
et puis finalement ils ont tous été
éjecté ou massacrer exterminer et
beaucoup sont venus en france non pas
comme mes parents qui étaient des
aristocrates russes parce qu'il parlait
le français mais parce qu'il croyait que
la france était le pays idéal des droits
de l'homme et qu'il savait que là il
pourrait au moins se regrouper alors il
y avait une particularité c'est qu'ils
vivent est assis sur leurs valises en
attendant de retourner en russie
il y avait une chose qu'il est
scandalisé il ne comprenait pas que la
communauté internationale laisse staline
massacrer son peuple et donc en silence
car c'est une immigration silencieuse
discrète il voulait pas faire de vagues
il ne voulait pas faire de politique
mais quand même ils ont eu est tellement
été choqué de ça que quand hitler s'est
prononcé contre le bolchevisme
quelques-uns ont été tentés de rejoindre
la wehrmacht et de se combattre auprès
des soldes alors effectivement et au
moment où éclate la seconde guerre
mondiale
ils ont trois choix en fait parce que
staline de son côté a reconstitué une
fin c'est ce qu'aurait dit oui en défaut
c'est pas vrai a dit qu'il avait
reconstitué une arme et kozak justement
pour faire pour s'opposer aux allemands
oui c'était pas des vraies causes
accessoires et ce n'est pas dans la
tradition puisqu'il n'était ni orthodoxe
nice ariz
et puis il ya aussi poutine qui en ce
moment fait la cour au kazakh mais c'est
des cosaques d'opérette rayonne à néma
les prêts y en a plus et ceux qui
étaient en france il y avait des
communautés un peu partout et ça très
peu de gens le savent
il y en avait en ardèche la vie dans le
jura il était éleveur de chevaux pour la
plupart agriculteurs et ouvriers
savez vous que à boulogne billancourt
chez renault et à ocz hindson qui est
accro tard j il y avait des ouvriers
cosaques et vous la regardiez 2000 kozak
tout le monde était kozak lama le le
boucher et et kozak le cordonnier et et
causa que les infirmières étaient
cosaques et surtout il avait cette chose
extraordinaire de rester entre eux en
autarcie voulait pas qu'on il voulait
être reconnaissant à la france d'avoir
accueilli mais il n'a prenait pas le
français alors évidemment les
générations suivantes se sont fondues à
la société française et ils ont à peu
près disparu maintenant mais ils ont
vraiment été alors on les aimait bien
comme vous voyez pas ce que faisait pas
de grève il ne se plaignait pas il avait
un sens de l'honneur chevillée au corps
alors j'ai choisi cette ambiance là
parce que je voulais prendre une héroïne
qui vient de très loin
c'est à dire que l'ascenseur social
quand je prétends qu'il continue à
exister en france
cette jeune femme qui est née dans un
milieu rural kozak loin de tout petit à
petit grâce à son intelligence et selena
elle arrive un trait au poste est serré
mais les grands causses
il ya plein de gens qui ont des origines
comme ça et qu'ils ont faits récents sur
ce qui est arrivé notamment à la ça
s'appelle vania vassia et la fille de
vastes ya là vous parlez de la fille de
wasteels mien mais il yad abord vania et
vassia il y en a un qui va choisir
effectivement d'aller se battre dans
l'année
vision que j'ai créée par l'armée
allemande ils vont se battre alors pas
lui particulièrement mais ils vont se
battre en yougoslavie en place en italie
qui est allé dans absolument yougoslavie
et le plus dramatique c'est que quand à
l'armistice les alliés plus
particulièrement les anglais les ont
livrés aux russes ils ont tous été
envoyés au goulag et ils ont tous été
avec leur famille ont plus avec leur
famille et leurs généraux ont été pendus
immédiatement alors donc et c'est une
histoire tragique mais je pense que ce
qui est le rôle du de l'écrivain de la
littérature c'est de rendre déchiffrable
des choses indéchiffrables et surtout de
donner un peu de poésie au malheur les
choses épouvantables qui nous arrive
il faut savoir les magnifier de manière
à ce que ça devienne romanesque et qu'on
puisse les supporter alors expliquez-moi
et puisqu'il ya des deux frères y en a
qui est chauffeur de taxi pourquoi il
aimait tant de russes blancs et de
cosaques donc chauffeur de taxi ans
parce que c'était le dernier métier
qu'il n'y avait pas besoin de diplôme de
compétence et que c'était aussi un
métier de chien il travaillait presque
24 heures sur 24
et puis ils n'avaient pas autre chose à
faire dés encore aujourd'hui les taxis
c'est vraiment le refuge
ddd les derniers maintenant c'est plus
difficile parce qu'il faut enfin pour
être taxi il faut payer russe la paix ya
plusieurs mamans bref c'est pas ça c'est
un métier quand même c'est un peu le bas
de l'échelle c'est le plus bas possible
alors là sonia la fille de vastes yade
devient énarque une des premières
énarque puisque les n'a été créée juste
après la seconde guerre mondiale
féministe puis secrétaire d'état quand
de gaulle revient au pouvoir
pourquoi en faire une secrétaire d'état
sous bédié laissé tant de l'ascenseur
social dont je me suis inspiré de gens
que je connais évidemment et puis et
surtout elle a connu mendès-france j'ai
connu un des sponsors a permis à partir
d'un certain moment parce que tout ce
qui touche la guerre de là j'étais trop
jeune je connais pas mais à partir des
années 50 g en chef chefs les mots roman
de toutes sortes de choses que j'ai vécu
moi-même j'aurais aimé faire de la
politique moi à oui moi c'est un peu un
ratage parce que je pense que j'étais
faite pour ça et comme j'étais trop
pauvre j'ai pas pu faire d'études et le
cinéma m'a attrapé très jeune à 16 ans
au prix normal autant la princesse faire
une carrière politique en france c'est
pas facile pourquoi pas j'ai pas que
j'imagine d'evry peut vous avez tort je
pense que même une princesse peut faire
la folie et princesses fauché avec zéro
argent
c'était toute façon j'étais dans la
prolétaire et ne jamais rien essayer de
récupérer depuis la fin du communisme en
disant c'est pas comme les hongrois les
polonais ou les roumains c'était trop
long vous comprenez tout a disparu
et puis en plus je ne sais pas mes
parents mon père a dit il y en a pour
cent ans
et quand ils sont venus en france e et
parler le français il était très
cosmopolite il voulait pas que nous
retournions là bas il pensait qu'on
avait été très injustement chasser et
qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de
continuer à souhaiter être russes
alors allez il stockera cyrus était un
petit peu responsables de ce crime et
bien sûr attendez moi mes parents vivent
et comme dans lambil dans des propriétés
immense mais quand même avec ce sens
cosmopolite
mon grand-père lisez le monde le
manchester guardian le frankfurter
allgemeine parler toutes les langues se
soucier plus facilement du monde que de
leurs propres peuples maudire un peu
donc ils l'ont pas volé cette révolution
d'accord
écoutez moi j'étais un petit de gauche
alors ma mère était horrifiée dit mais
comment c'est possible parce que quand
on réfléchit et je continue à être
marxiste c'est une comment dire une
grille de lecture
imparable tu te demande d'où vient
l'argent tout de suite on comprend tout
c'est pas difficile
1 d'où vient l'argent ça c'est la
première simple le soda dialects rice a
listé les marxistes vous aviez aucune
aucun avenir dans la politique de macha
méril bien fait de vous tromper
je pense que nous aurons j'aurais fait
mange pas et puis surtout j'aurais
probablement muté aussi les gars vous
êtes également la présidente d'honneur
du festival du cinéma russe qui dure
jusqu'au 9 mars on va regarder tout de
suite la bande-annonce
[Musique]
y'a pailloux
le festival se déroule dans cinq lieux
où balzac au studio 28 au max linder ou
christine 21 et au centre spirituel et
culturel orthodoxe russe construit par
jean michel wilmotte dont vous parlez
dans votre roman également alors vous
êtes la présidente d'honneur emmanuel
carrère et le président du jury d'une
compétition juste un mot il est comment
le cinéma russe à voile à gérer mon
temps de m'occuper de ça parce que il ya
une sorte de désertion du cinéma russe
depuis quelque temps à croire que les
distributeurs pense que ça n'est pas
suffisamment commercial alors qu'ils ont
un cinéma extraordinaire alors notre
festival est un mélange entre des films
cultes des films du répertoire pour que
les jeunes les vois pas ce que je sûr
que quand on passe quand passent les
cigognes ou quand on passe guerre et
paix de bondartchouk c'est un succès
formidable c'était l'année dernière
c'est un extrait inédit mais vous vous
rappelez on est alors il ya un vivier
extraordinaire de films plus les
nouveaux alors le nouveau cinéma il est
comme tous les cinémas du monde c'est à
dire il se cherche
quelquefois il ya des films plus ou
moins réussi plus ou moins violents mais
en tout cas ils ont une école le fig
je vous assure que c'est une école
extrêmement riche et stricte et puis
surtout il ya cette fascination qui a
toujours existé entre les français et
les russes ça continue c'est à dire nous
nous étonnons de leur fougue et eux ils
s'étonnent de notre bon sens de notre
rationalisme ils se trompent parce que
les français sont aussi fous que les
russes mais mais qui n'empêche qu'il ya
ce mythe comme ça de connaissances et
alors ja regardez vous connaissez les
noms des acteurs américains
et on connaît pas les noms des acteurs
russes d'accord ils sont imprononçables
m'enfin quand même il ya une sorte de
erreur là que je pense qu'il faut
corriger qu'en plus c'est une des
questions qui ne fâchent pas trop la
culture entre la russie et la france je
pense qu'il faut absolument leur tendre
la main
ils ont du mal vous savez les bons
cinéastes là bas c'est pas si simple
il souffre et ils ont des censures
terrible d'ailleurs moi j'ai une soirée
jeux présente je vous invite tous avec
plaisir mercredi le 4 mars
je présente le film du neuf cinéastes
qui s'appelle lydia beau brun
ça s'appelle dans ce pays la phto
iranien est l'histoire d'un petit
village très près de moscou
vive dans l'ems milles alors c'est à
dire les enfants jouent dans la boue y a
pas d'acheteur la saleté le tout le
monde les p&t du matin au soir
le dentiste et le ferrailleur qui
arrache avec une taille et du de la
vodka bon et ça ils à la pauvre elle est
mal traité en russie parce qu'on dit
qu'elle donne une mauvaise image de la
russie et surtout l'outil n'a dit
qu'elle fait de l'humour avec la misère
humaine
alors expliquez moi comment chaplin a
fait et comment font tous les grands
humoristes des cancres si on ne rit pas
de la misère il n'y a pas d'humour voilà
donc je vous engage tous à venir
en effet si je commence ce soir évoluera
chacon soit 9 mars
voilà
[Musique]
yves michaud vous êtes philosophe
critique d'art vous avez dirigé l'école
des beaux-arts de paris de 1989 à 1997
aujourd'hui vous publiez ceci n'est pas
une tulipe chez fayard
c'est sur l'art le luxe et
l'enlaidissement des villes le titre
fait allusion évidemment à la sculpture
book étoffe tulipe de jeff koons qui a
fait polémique et qui trône désormais
dans les jardins des champs elysées on
l'a vu tout à l'heure en photo le
revoici ce bouquet de tulipes alors va
pas revenir sur la polémique pascal
occupe une partie de votre livre mais
dieu sait si elle a déjà fait couler
beaucoup d'encre qu'est ce qui vous a
intéressé dans ce bouquet de tulipes
depuis qu'il est installé
qu'est-ce que ça à symbolise pour vous
écoutez je n'aurais pas écrit un livre
uniquement sur sur ce bouquet est sûre
sur cette sculpture simplement j'ai
commencé à y réfléchir au moment de la
polémique
et puis j'ai suivi un peu le détail et
petit à petit j'ai tiré le fil si vous
voulez de la pelote donc d'abord je me
suis posé la question de savoir qu'est
ce que c'est qu'une sculpture urbaine
qui est pas petit 1 60 tonnes 12 mètres
de haut et court qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une sculpture comme ça je dirais
monument à quoi quelle est la
signification de ce genre d'objets dans
la ville en général
ensuite je me suis intéressé au fait que
comme c'est de l'art contemporain ultra
financiarisé sur le fait que cet art-là
à partir du moment où il vaut cher et où
les artistes sont sont très connus et où
il ya des bons sentiments puisque là
c'est un hommage aux victimes des
attentats 2015 passé sur le basson sur
la plaisanterie si on veut je me suis
demandé je dirai comment quand il se
fait qu'on regarde pas ces objets sont
les plantes quelque part on les a on les
accepte c'était un cadeau on les reçoit
on les plante quelque part et au fond
les a pas regardés
je suis dire ça j'ai analysé disons là
c'est la sémiologie de la faire et c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est pas trop
des tulipes corsa correspond beaucoup à
la rhd de jeff koons qui a un contenu
sexuel très fort et qui est très
souvent très pornographique de l'aveu
même du sculpteur bon ensuite je me suis
intéressé au montage de l'opération
assez là où soit élargie sur la ville en
général c'est comment se fait-il qu'on
finance des projets comme ça qu'ils
finançaient d'où ça vient hélas germond
j'ai regardé tous les documents et j'ai
vu que au fond les le petit groupe de
paix de décideurs et de financeurs de
cette opération représente le monde du
luxe de l'immobilier de l'art
contemporain financiarisé et du tourisme
et donc ça élargit oussama élargi ma
réflexion sur le direct qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la ville aujourd'hui
et quand on quand elle elle vouée au
luxe à la touristification et je dirais
à la consommation culturelle vous dit en
fait qu'on est en train de faire des
grandes villes européennes des parcs
d'attractions abbas a dit ça oui mais ça
je dirais que je m'en étais rendu compte
bien avant parce que j'ai travaillé avec
des auteurs et avec des gens à barcelone
vient de la caixa notamment les gens qui
est la caixa de de catalogne qui possède
l'immeuble de gaudi la pedrera et en
2005 on avait organisé un grand colloque
international sur justement les défis du
tourisme culturel et le titre d'ailleurs
du colloque c'était les défis du
tourisme et les réponses qu'on peut
apporter parce que la pedrera c'est un
immeuble d'habitation ou un carré qui
est magnifique mais où il rentre plus
d'un million de personnes par an qui
rendent par l'escalier principal et qui
descendent par l'escalier de service et
qui consomment littéralement la pedrera
dire c'est la détruit bon il y avait
jean louis à ce colloque est belle merde
san gimignano aussi qui voit défiler 8
millions de touristes dans l'idéal d'un
bon jovi live
mais kick années qu'il est dans les
bronzes l allier une rue passante rue
principale une rue principale arpentés
par des touristes mais ça et je crois
que tout c'est pareil pour le coeur de
vienne à l'intérieur du ring
mais à paris je crois que maintenant ça
cssa s'est emballé si vous voulez et on
est vraiment dans une opération
viendrait presque concertée de 2-2-2
disneylandisation culturel et de luxure
isation du coeur de paris ça va depuis
et ça ira depuis l'arc de triomphe
jusqu'au marais je vais dire est
initialement kunz avait avait quasiment
choisi l'endroit où ils mettraient 500
sont vos réponses culture c'était entre
devant le palais de tokyo entre le musée
d'art moderne et et le palais de la
ville de paris le palais de tokyo
l'emplacement lui a été refusée et quand
on voit ce qu'il a finalement fait c'est
heureusement mais il va se retrouver au
coeur du nouvel espace des jardins des
champs elysées avec la la rénovation
complète du grand palais du petit palais
du palais de la découverte qui est en
train d'être mise en place par chris
dercon à une échéance de trois ou quatre
ans je veux dire donc on livre paris je
dirais à une disneylandisation à partir
de là j'ai réfléchi je dirais d'une part
sur les opérateurs parce que ça consiste
à donner générer la mainmise sur
l'espace public à des opérateurs privés
aussi a aussi aussi je dirais
professionnels qu'ils soient je veux
dire je ne pose pas la question de leurs
compétences
est ce qu'on a le droit de privatiser
complètement les décisions concernant
l'espace public
et puis à partir de là ça m'a fait
réfléchir à quelque chose que que je
sentais comme nous tous mais qu' on le
voyait pas dire c'est finalement
pourrissement de la ville
l'enlaidissement systématique de la
ville par tout ce qu'on y met un et le
mobilier urbain les oeuvres d'art que
toutes les choses qui rendent la vie
agréable et facile ça va depuis les
transports et trottinettes les mobiliser
le fameux encombrement et celle en
nombre quand vous parlez on fait une
pause vous avez fait une bonne bande
annonce on fait et on revient et tout de
suite après sur l'encombrement
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais il y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique au
smic
l'euro ne fonctionne pas sinon on
n'aurait pas eu ce gros sel elle a eu
avec la grèce je suis pas vraiment pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro on
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
c'est une bonne chose
vous pouvez pas vous réjouir d'avoir
pays qui est sous perfusion sous
assistance respiratoire en permanence
j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks et de
julian assange pour la première fois
quand j'ai vu les images filmées depuis
l'hélicoptère en irak
je pense qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre
ce fils de [ __ ] illégalement c'était
historique
il n'est pas d'avoir un journaliste
indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonyme en lien avec le média
qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté mais je
n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde à feu
il y avait beaucoup de jalousie dans
l'immédiat traditionnelle envers
wikileaks est en vert assange en
particulier pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme donc ils vont accuser d'étaler des
excréments sur les murs roses
ce qui est fou
du hall et julian assange et à l'
isolement dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine
alors je crois que c'est le sort qui
l'attend
on a de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont atteints d'obésité on a de plus en
plus d'enfants qui sont baisse de plus
en plus tôt l'obésité génère 18 autres
maladies derrière apnées du sommeil
diabète cancer l'hypertension artérielle
infertilité hommes et femmes
moi ce que je vois c'est ce que ça coûte
aux individus en terme psychologique en
terme médical en termes sociétale en
termes professionnels et ça ça fait des
dégâts considérables
ce qui est fait en france par an chose
pour pas dire rien ça ne se soigne pas à
coup de spots télé ça ne se soigne pas à
coups de livres ça se soigne avec des
véritables médecin tout ce qui peut être
fait c'est pas moi je peux passer soeur
de moncade c'est faux ça commence chez
soi tout de suite maintenant
et
il
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui macha méril
la présidente d'honneur du 6e festival
du cinéma russe est l'auteur de vases ni
à bastia et la fille de bastia alexis hk
pour son nouvel album comme un ours
prend une florence dupré la tour pour
pucelle un nouveau volume de son
autobiographie en bande dessinée et yves
michaud pour son livre ceci n'est pas
une tulipe qui s'en prend donc à
l'encombrement des villes notamment par
les oeuvres d'art mais pas seulement les
oeuvres d'art vous dit ça vient ça c'est
devenu du mobilier urbain pour vous ça
veut dire qu'on veut c'est comme les
feux rouges comme les bambous rade
je pense que les barrières qu'on voit
partout je pense qu'il ya eu il ya une
continuité complète entre les oeuvres
d'art condom on encombrent l'espace
urbain le mobilier urbain pour pour que
la ville soit consommer de manière
agréable et ce mobilier urbain en plus
on le design je veux dire on le change
régulièrement regarder la manière dont
on a changé les abris bus par exemple à
paris le dire on l'a on voulait classer
la journée où les kiosques à journaux on
les rend un peu plus on les rend un peu
plus le flottant un liquide comme ça je
veux dire épique et en fait c'est
quelque chose que je sentais que nous
sentons tous parce que et qui dès que
j'en parle les gens disent mes petits
c'est bien sûr c'est vrai quand on ne
regarde plus qui a regardé mais qu'on
regarde ce qui est entre on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya une forêt de choses qui envahit
l'espace urbain qui comptent qui
constitue un bruit visuel insupportable
c'est un bruit un bruit de marche un
bruit pour le plan pour enjamber la
carte la réduction des taux si même un
bruit tout court parce que veut dire
vous avez les vélos vous avez les
trottinettes vous avez les les scooters
même les scooters qui sont guy sont
silencieux vous avez une sorte de
tohu-bohu visuel auditif et je dirai au
dos logique vous mentionnez pas les
voitures mais oui mais les voitures du à
terme y en aura deux mots il y en aura
de moins en moins c'est ce qui est visé
mais dans toutes ces villes là je veux
dire et pas seulement paris dans toutes
ces villes là qui sont livrés au
tourisme finalement la ville devient
invivable et c'est un encombrement de
l'esprit et on n'a plus alors dans le
même temps on nous écrit on nous fait
des discours sur le fait que
promeneurs de baudelaire le promeneur de
valter benyamine la ville 0 messi plus
vrai on peut plus se promener dans la
ville on peut plus en profiter et donc
moi ce à partir de là il ya pire que le
il ya presque pire que kunz c'est le
coeur de joana vasconcelos elle à l'afp
en atteignant un écho qui était enseigné
mission il ya pas longtemps d'ailleurs
elle serait pas contente de vous en fait
c'est incroyable parce que d'abord c'est
une oeuvre d'art qu est très médiocre
mais ensuite si quand vous la regardez
elle est au milieu d'une forêt visuel un
tintin insupportable intolérable
il ya des piquets partout des la
signalétique des annonces des feux
rouges
des potelets vie réelle elle en est même
invisible c'est le coeur en est même
invisible c'est une oeuvre médiocre mais
c'est sans état et je voyais de ne pas
les illustrer juste bons à rien donc
voilà dix longueurs d'onde je dirais ça
il y en a partout maintenant là on
capable de tramway sans maître d oeuvre
ça on leur reprochait aussi c'est que
souvent on les met n'importe où on ne
sait pas quoi en faire dites vous dans
les commandes
et puis après on sait plus où les mais
non les commandes pas dans le cadre du
bouquet de tulipes de jeff koons mais il
avait il en est risque à dos il voulait
que ce soit un endroit précis on a
cherché un autre où on sait pas quoi en
faire et on savait les gens ont pas
voulu à la villette toumi a dit qu'il
allait figurer à ce que c'était belgrade
dos s'était passé n'était pas gratuit il
fallait des financements énorme non la
l'italie lancement il était déjà assurée
mais assurer les financements c'est en
ce sens que c'est plus qu'une opération
esthétique c'est aussi une opération
esthétique au financière ça c'est autre
chose c'est pas vraiment directement le
sujet maintenant mais en fait on ne sait
plus quoi faire
en fait de la commande et puis ensuite
on met quelque part mais on est on
imagine aussi qu'il faut des corps et le
mouvement des gilets jaunes a quand même
eu un avantage énorme c'est de détruire
beaucoup de toutes les décorations qu'on
avait musclé rond-point les bois en
menant à la zone sinistrée rooney man au
cassoulet ratera les abonnements à
l'olive
c'est indécent et donc moi j'ai dit au
fond - basse et plus je vais revenir
pourquoi mettre moi on en est là qu on
en enlève on enlevait fois arrêté d'en
mettre
et puis on enlevait vous dites aussi
vous êtes pour qu'il y ait moins de
bureaucratie parce qu'au fond c'est une
production de la principale route bien
sûr c'est une production de la
bureaucratie parce que vous avez plein
de comités lambda qui qui s'activent à
faire des commandes
et puis qui s'activent à vérifier que
les commandes sont conformes au cahier
de au cahier de charges
et puis de fil en aiguille on se
retrouve avec élection on sait plus où
le mettre et non on le plante là où on
peut je prends les exemples des
sculptures de tim mittelberg la de
capitaine dreyfus et qu'on a fourré dans
des dans des squares on les avaient
commandées
je suppose pour pour célébrer dreyfus
est aussi peut-être pour refaire pour
célébrer team mittelberg qui était
quelqu'un de très estimable mais au bout
du compte on savait plus où les mettre
on a mis françois mauriac je sais pas
trop non là c'est le square pierre
l'affût
on les fours n'importe où et il ya même
des enfants on les démonte pas ce qu'on
sait plus les maîtres donne l'exemple de
clara clara des qui a été de richard
serra commandée par la ville de paris
qui bouchaient les tuileries et après
l'exposition de ces rats on l'a démonté
on l'a mis dans le square de choisy
houle est devenu et à new york parce
qu'il est bête problème à new york avec
une oeuvre depuis new york est on un
jury et là j'ai trouvé que la réaction
des gens à l'époque comme je m'occupe
beaucoup d'art j'aurais dû être du côté
des défenseurs de ces rames et non les
gens avait tout à fait raison
on une sculpture n'est pas fait pour
empêcher les gens de traverser une
un espace un square mais un autre
exemple d'encombrement urbain regarder
je veux dire la manière dont le les
jardins des tuileries sont bourrés de
sculptures et même si elles sont bonnes
il ya un moment où trop c'est trop
je prends l'exemple aussi de l'arbre au
des voyelles de de penan de merci on le
voit pas pousser un arbre en bronze de
20 mètres et couché parmi les arbres
attendez-vous à dire un jour quelqu'un
m'a donné rendez vous vers l'arbre
voyelles j'ai pas trouvé l'endroit parce
que il est littéralement invisible là ça
va encore mais pourquoi commander des
choses partout non mais regardez aussi
que la moindre le moindre espace d'herbe
est entouré par des grillages et puis on
met des cabines de jardiniers le jardin
du luxembourg
ces deux marques à drac 1 et un bric à
brac pas pousser l'iran préfère ça aux
fêtes foraines veille des fêtes foraines
y en a de moins en moins dans les camps
mais je trouve ce que j'attaque aussi
dans mon livre c'est la manière dont on
couvre le si les bâtiments de ces bâches
publicitaires
ça c'est de faire chic alors que si vous
en parlez d'un chai de texte un
échafaudage s'appelle bo et du coup on
enlève la grande roue de marcel campion
1 parce que ça fait un peu fait à neuf
places et lacombe et le luo qui a la
mainmise sur les jardins des tuileries à
récupérer clamper ont vu là bas c'est
pour l'argent je suis pour le livre
s'intitule ceci n'est pas une tulipe et
levon enlevons enlevons louisiane paraît
prêt chez fayard
[Musique]
alexis hk votre nouvel album s'intitule
comme un ours lors cette allusion une
allusion à la solitude à la force
l agressivité oui c'est une allusion à
une solitude
je trouve assez finalement à la fois
contemporaine et immémorial mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans une période
de retranchement vous êtes donc ayad
sombre car les périodes les seconds
votre album
ouais on sent qu'on est dans une période
sombre à vos yeux j'ai le sentiment
qu'on est dans une période très sombre
mais pas une période sans espoir une
période dans la quête derrière laquelle
il ya sans doute une lumière une sèche
cabine plutôt bien à l'album les coudes
dans l'ordre
ça commence mal et ça se finit plutôt
bien là et ça recommence ça commence mal
écoutons un extrait de votre clip les
pieds dans la boue
les pieds dans la boue la tête dans les
étoiles qui comme le coq notre totem
animal entend le courroux des âmes qui
saigne fasciné par le gourou qui
s'agitent sur la scène il parle de
l'avenir de l'homme honte à tous ceux
qui contreviennent à ses dogmes il
traite les noirs de singer pactisent
avec les plus noires instinct que les
crises at ease
[Musique]
tant de responsables au misère du peuple
offusqué
[Musique]
les boucs émissaires risquent bel
c'est sûr
[Musique]
mais chambaud
bizien creed aux gauchistes de mahler
responsables du déclin de la famille et
des valeurs se préparent au grand retour
des fossoyeurs qui fâchent is encore du
beurre pour les vendeurs de valises ça
t'a manqué d'avoir à nouveau des copains
qui viennent de voir un banc à 5 heures
du matin illumine ton visage d'une
étrange portée
cacheux tu dans ta ka
[Musique]
et
tendresse
du peuple offusquer les boucs émissaires
risquent d'être assez surbooké boat
people vraiment roulotte
la cites
aux enfants save et unijambiste
devrons-nous nous tenir à carreau sous
le drapeau
nous faire des uv qui font blanchir on
est en pleine régression on al
impression qu entendez coût de cet album
les xixe et jusque là oui j'ai
l'impression on pensait en tout cas dans
ma dans ma jeunesse
il ya eu un moment de un grand moment de
naïveté ou on n'en pensaient qu'on était
passé au dessus de beaucoup de choses
qui reviennent en force aujourd'hui du
racisme primaire des des retranchements
idéologiques religieux et c'est vrai que
quand on a grandi dans l'idéal de
françois mitterrand en 81 ce genre de
choses mais au bout du compte a aussi un
petit petit quand même j'étais petit
mais je me sens bien moi de 80 c'était
la fête dans les rues terre et je ne je
ne porte aucun jugement là dessus je dis
que on a un sentiment voilà de
régression alors est-ce qu'on se joue de
nous ou est ce que c'est vraiment un
état du monde intime de chaque personne
je ne crois pas je pense qu'il ya des
forces en présence qui sont qui sont qui
sont qui sont dures qui soyez des fruits
sauvages
il ya une espèce de parfum de guerre
civile qui flotte dans vos chansons mais
tempérée par le ukulélé comme c'est ça
qui donne à côté hawaïen à moi je ne
suis qu'un je ne suis qu'un humble
chanteur je ne fais pas de politique je
partage des ressentis et j'ai eu un
sentiment comme ça que j'ai encore et
que voilà et qui que pour l'instant je
n'ai pas réussi à faire disparaître le
tour ne voit revenir des choses qui me
surprennent le tournant se serait
peut-être les attentats de novembre 2015
vous leur consacrer d'ailleurs une une
chanson au vendredi 13 novembre
oui on va on va écouter un extrait du
clip toujours cette attitude marianne
l'après-midi a déroulé
des oeuvres tous
jean les terrasses bondées de bièvres en
route
alors pas vis est en flammes
mais attaquer par les loups zégarés
quand le camp 7 1
vite et que
foule s'est mise à crier
et toutes nos illusions perdues en
quelques secondes à peine
consumer par le feu
et les larmes des hommes
qui sait
une douleur qui revient ne fasse qui
nous multi
le sang des innocents les traces
indélébiles
c'était tu ne perds le journée
pour un autre
[Musique]
le mariage
s'est mise à pleurer
comme m'adore alexis hk y avait eu des
attentats avant à paris notamment ray et
pas seulement à paris ce sont quelques
illusions qui se sont envolés pour vous
ce jour là précisément l'illusion que
que tout ça peut fonctionner que tout ça
peut tenir
et puis il faut des explosions il faut
des des débordements pour que on retombe
de ça et peut-être que ça nous
permettent de réfléchir
peut-être que ça nous permet de nous
remettre en question mais l'illusion
dont je parle c'est sans doute la mienne
celle d'un confort sans doute trop trop
aveugle trop aveugle et et c'est vrai
que ça m'a comme comme beaucoup je pense
que ça m'a réveillé ça m'a réveillé et
moi j'essaie attentats je les ai pas vus
comme une guerre de civilisation je les
ai vus comme un malaise humains profonds
un malentendu humain profond bien au
delà des clivages des clivages de
religion ce genre de choses pour moi ça
va même pas jusque là c'est c'est comme
laisser des cdc des malentendus avec là
d'une mauvaise cible une mauvaise cible
un mauvais combat enfin il n'y a rien
qui va il ya presque une absurdité
derrière tout ça tout en vous de vous et
partys et jamais d'une certaine gaieté
on le voit bien d'ailleurs parce que là
on a passé plutôt la deuxième moitié du
clip et on va vers la gaieté j'ai
toujours envie moi de voir de l'espoir
mais c'est aussi parce que j'estime que
c'est le rôle d'un chanteur de deux à la
fois par les deux choses noires si il
les ressent mais de ne pas se complaire
dedans j'essaie de voilà je navigue
toujours entre une ombre et de lumière
mais j'ai aussi des moments magnifiques
dans ma vie est même illégal toujours et
la vie gagne toujours non voyant la fois
que la dernière chanson du disque un bon
jour oui il est bien
extraits un beau jour
[Musique]
un beau jour je parte il est loin d'ici
bas j'oublierai ton visage et la douceur
de t pain
j'oublierai les bafana mais les coups
bas
j'oublierai le goût des larmes de seine
toi tu sais toi
entre deux fois
entre données
entre deux diables
deux cents jeunes u
j'y revois
si c'est pau
dans ma
laon
un beau jour je partirai loin d'ici bas
j'y rêve retrouver simon ipsi mais ma
pizza
m
[Musique]
qui est depuis si longtemps partie je me
console en rêve en vous va voir loin
d'ici
entre deux femmes
entre eux de nous
[Musique]
il
deux cents jeunes u
j'irai voir
ici c'est beau
vu d'en bas
là
[Musique]
hexis hk comme sa dernière chanson du
disque que je me suis demandée c'est
annoncé votre départ en exil ou votre
fils de l'emba vous plutôt un apaisement
c'est le moment du discours où on admire
voile afin de revoir absolument
de toute façon tout ça c'est que des
chansons d'hier justement vous avez vous
allez être retourné là la tournée
s'annonce riche en date il ya d'ailleurs
25 qui sont déjà complètes
en consacrant vous allez vous faire pour
exorciser le côté dépressif que
pourraient prendre ces le chanson vise
les unes après les autres
je crois que le seul remède est dans le
l autodérision
moi je m'amuse beaucoup de moi même j'ai
toujours été un peu accablée depuis
depuis très longtemps j'ai pas tendre la
dépression mais c'est une sorte de
léthargique sakima qui m'a saisi depuis
j'étais vieux très jeune je ne jouais
pas beaucoup avec les autres gt j'avais
un côté un peu sauvage et si j'avais pas
fait de cyril pas fait de chansons je
sais je ne sais pas où je serais
aujourd'hui je pense pas qu'on serait en
train de discuter et donc je m'amuse
avec ça beaucoup sur scène et les
chansons sont enrobées de de speech et
de sketches qui se sera à l'olympia le
18 avril mais avant ça vous serez lieu
le 8 mars à granville le 6 mars à
granville le 7 mars à saint-arnoult le
11 à niort etc etc beaucoup de dates
on les retrouve sur votre site
[Musique]
laure florence dupré la tour vous
publiez pucelle chez dargaud
l'héroïne s'appelle florence c'est
autobiographique il s'appelle toujours
florence de 10 ans cachez pas vous et
décrivez alors en adolescente ou en pré
adolescentes totalement ignorante des
choses du sexe
néanmoins avec un avis assez assez
tranché sur la question qu'on voit sur
ces sur cet album alors vous êtes en
êtes très jeune donc on se dit encore
dans votre génération il y avait des
jeunes filles qui ne savaient pas les
règles qu'ils ne savaient pas les
relations sexuelles ne savez pas comment
vous et des enfants mais ça parce que
toujours y en a encore toujours innover
sont là grâce à internet s'émerveillant
abouti les jeunes filles et les jeunes
garçons sont quand même un peu moins mal
dégrossi mais moi je n'avais pas du tout
accès justement à cette ces informations
je venais d'une je viens toujours d'une
famille qui est qui était très
religieuse très très catholique vous
viviez en plus en argentine on est dans
un milieu assez assez assez refermer
replié sur lui-même qui est le milieu
des expatriés et donc nous vivions
vraiment en vase clos et avec une très
très grande protection de la part de ma
mère surtout notamment sur les choses de
la sexualité est une famille très
hiérarchisée très je vous rappelle qu'il
est déjà dans cruel avant cela une
famille très hiérarchisée le père et la
mère ne dit rien quand le père dit
quelque chose
oui absolument donc depuis la plus
tendre enfance j'ai vu des exemples
dans ma famille qui ont fait de moi
pendant très longtemps une femme assez
misogyne
il y avait un dessin très amusant où
vous voyez des animaux qui font des
bébés
vous voyez votre mère qui attend un
enfant ce sera votre père frère
oui et vous vous réalisez à ce moment-là
qu'il vous manque une information à une
information quand même assez un palace
et comment on fait comment fait-on
comment fait-on alors je dois dire que
j'explique dans cet album fut celle que
j'ai eu quand même une éducation je
dirais 19e east c'est à dire que je j'ai
vu des informations d'abord en regardant
les animaux oui oui en plus vous vivez à
la campagne voilà donc en regardant les
animaux et c'est déjà bien c'est à dire
est que nos même temps en même temps on
voit pas vraiment on voit des mouvements
mais ça reste assez mystérieux sur leur
isolement
que font-ils quand il est revenu en
france il faut dire vous habitiez dans
les normes domaine très très beau oui et
là où il ya plein d'animaux énormément
énormément mais j'ai cette culture du
secret et du silence ainsi une culture
du vide
et quand on ne dit pas les choses que ce
soit au niveau des secrets de famille au
niveau du secret d'ailleurs les enfants
les petits enfants surtout imagine
énormément ils ont un pouvoir de
l'imagination extraordinaire et donc il
imagine tout et comme les alpes le peu
d'information humaine que j'avais été
assez angoissante
j'ai compris petit à petit qu'il était
question de sens pour les femmes dans
mon esprit le sang était forcément
corrélée à la réelle à crier au crime ou
à quelque chose d'assez d' assez
angoissant petit à petit une forme
d'angoissé s'est installé une forme de
une forme d'angoissé physique c'est à
dire que ça passait vraiment par rapport
à des pressions au niveau du plexus
solaire c'est quelque chose qui était
très présent chez moi et que j'ai gardé
pendant très longtemps à cela s'associe
à une image de la delà de la sexualité
qui était véhiculée par la religion
notamment avec des mots qui était très
négative et alors le voilà une planche
vous aller à la messe tous les dimanches
en france arrive et on vous y répétait
que l'homme ait été le chef de famille
par exemple plus les femmes devaient lui
obéit
oui alors c'est ça mais voilà des joues
pas papa tous les dimanches jamais dans
les années 70 et on dit encore ça dans
les églises châteaux non-bâti d'autant
que je n'y suis pas allé un mois dans
mais rien pour vous le disais ça oui
bien sûr après il ya de nombreux
nombreux mouvements un de nos nombreux
nombreuses façons d'être croyant chez
dans l'église mais bon voilà celle que
j'ai celle que j'ai pratiqué était quand
même assez classique alors celui qui n'y
avait pas quelle église à à l'école
c'était pareil puis que vous racontez
que l'histoire de france qu'on vous
enseigner les femmes avaient été effacés
oui oui oui oui c'était très angoissant
méritoire en avait que jeanne d'arc de
la pucelle la pucelle d'ailleurs avec il
avait accédé à ajustement la gloire une
gloire s'il d'un mec mais les familles
parce que eh oui avec de survie
l'histoire bien si on est assez trouble
là dessus mais en tout cas celle qu'on
nous racontait dans l'enfance nous
montrait une femme qui avait réussi
parce qu'elle était plus elle donc je
savais que j'allais devoir accéder à la
sexualité puisque l'image que j'avais de
mes parents en tout cas du couple et de
moi en tant que si c'était avoir des
enfants être mariée mais je devais en
même temps être pucelle pour accéder à
la gloire c'était très très
contradictoires très très très embêtant
d'un point de vue du service à des
choses de match est pas et donc j'ai
assez vite intégré le fait que avoir une
vie sexuelle
c'est une chose très néfaste ça ne
devait pas se dire c'était la chose
qu'on ne dit pas donc la chose qu'on ne
dit pas et donc il ya quelques quelques
passages avec ma petite soeur qui arrive
qui tout petit qui
la trois ans elle est à l'âge où
justement on commence à découvrir ces
choses là elle arrive tout nu devant
tout le monde et se tripotent à un
endroit que l'on connaît tous
enfin bon presque tous et vous ne
connaissiez pas et que moi je ne
connaissais pas mais je me jules moudimé
mondiaux mais quelle horreur c'est une
prostituée et et dire ça de d'un petit
enfant quand on a quand on a 13 ans de
violence extrême dès la première planche
qu'on va tout à l'heure allez arrive au
plus tôt à la fin de l'album et on voit
que vous êtes reforcer dans votre jeu
absolument tout brand force de vote dans
votre choix d'être un homme au fond tout
en étant tout en détestant les hommes et
et en même temps déjà attiré par le jeu
ne détestait pas du tout les hommes au
contraire je souhaitais faire partie de
leur bande
non ça n'est pas du tout une détestation
c'était un désir profond d'avoir des
attributs de pouvoir eux que je n'avais
pas je pensais en fait pouvoir faire
partie de ce clan là c'était
complètement idiot de ma part parce que
je sais pas parce que quand on arrive à
la fin de l'album il ya une suite on se
dit qu'il va nous raconter comment il
est devenu homosexuel info paru dans le
sun red is a répété une bonne suite wii
fait louis je ne vous connais pas donc
je me sens pas bien du tout tout ce que
j'avais pu choisir comme option mais
effectivement ça aurait pu être le
portrait de quelqu'un qui se refuse à
être une femme et qui veut absolument en
soit c'est pas c'est pas une évidence
être une femme va
je pense qu'il ya certaines personnes
qui réussissent à le devenir et d'autres
pour qui ça reste très compliquée
puisque on a trop de poids sur les
épaules et de et de discours
contradictoire avec des dés ce qu'on
appelle des double contrainte
on nous dit une chose et son contraire
on doit allier les deux ensemble et
particulièrement dans l'album décidé
puisque là aussi avait pas d' héroïne de
bande dessinée ce que je comprends très
bien quand vous étiez au fond - y avait
pas d'héroïne asile des castings c'est
vrai j'ai pas eu la chance d'avoir accès
au travail de claire bretécher je salue
aujourd'hui je travaille je salue son
travail sur sa carrière je ne lisais pas
les frustrés ou non non non non non marc
morize et blueberry quand même mais a
donc que j'ai adoré bien sûr je
m'identifiais tout de suite aux
personnages mais ce personnage n'était
pas moi c'était un garçon et tous les
autres personnages que je pouvais
rencontrer
que ce soit en cours d'histoire en cours
de littérature en bande destinée
je ne pouvais pas
me projeter dans ses personnages ça
s'intitule pucelle ses premiers volumes
des boutons il ya le volume suivant
quand paraîtra t-il l'année prochaine il
s'appellera confirmer ça paraîtra chez
dargaud
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission vania vassia
et la fille de vassia de macha méril
c'est chez liana levi et le festival du
cinéma russe dont elle est présidente
d'honneur c'est jusqu'au 9 mars à paris
ceci n'est pas une tulipe le livre
d'yves michaud c'est chez fayard
le nouvel album d'alexis hk s'intitule
comme un ours et il sera en concert à
l'olympia le 18 avril
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
et